>>Male speaker: It is my pleasure today to
introduce Allen Downey.
He's a professor of Computer Science at Olin
College, and a lot of us, he's also the author
of at least three books
for O'Reilly: Think Python, Think Stats, and
Think Complexity.
Looking at an intersecting world of ideas
around, using software to explore other concepts.
And he's a professor
at Olin College of Computer Science.
A lot of us here at Google,
know him from his stint as a visiting scientist,
and Nathan Glasgow's
group Under Hiatus.
And just a quick personal anecdote.
I took
this book home on Tuesday, by Wednesday afternoon,
there was already
an iterated prisoner's dilemma tournament
going on in my house when I got home, so,
it's interesting, so thank you very much Allen.
>>Allen: Thank you very much David.
Thank you all for coming.
it's a lot of fun for me to be back.
I was just pointing out
the part in the book that's about you.
So enjoy that.
If you want to follow along, that's the URL
for the slides I'm using.
There are a few links in the slides, so if
you go to that, you'll be
able to follow those links.
So as David mentioned,
when we were talking about this book, Think
Complexity,
I want to start out by telling you a little
bit of the history
of how this book came around.
I teach at Olin College, which
is a small engineering college in Needham.
It's relatively new,
it's only been operating for about ten years.
The mission of the college
is to create an innovative engineering program.
And specifically for Computer Science,
we needed to create a curriculum
that made sense for engineers.
We don't offer a degree in Computer Science,
we offer degrees in engineering.
Students can concentrate in Computer Science,
which is kind of like doing a minor,
but we didn't want to just do an Engineering
major
with a C.S. minor.
We thought that was an opportunity
to do something richer than that.
So what we weren't looking for is a Department
of Computer Science.
What we ended up doing is, taking the ideas
in Computer Science,
took the whole curriculum,
and you can imagine if each class is a box,
full of stuff, we just took all the stuff
and dumped it out on the table,
threw away the boxes, and started rearranging
the stuff.
'Cause a lot of the groupings of ideas are
historical,
and might not be the best choices for a current
curriculum.
So, for example,
if you have the luxury of offering lots of
classes,
you'll have an Operating Systems class, a
Networking class,
and a Databases class,
and there might not be explicit connections
between those.
But if you now take all those pieces,
and dump them on the table,
and say I'm going to teach one class that
covers those three topics,
well, you lose something,
because you're not going to be able
to cover everything that you did before.
But you gain something because if you take
Operating Systems
and Networks together, you're naturally talking
about Distributed Systems.
If you take File Systems and Databases together,
you're naturally
looking at a File System as a kind of Database,
or a Database as a kind of File System,
and I think there are ideas that come out
of that.
So we wrote about it, and we called it
"The Small Footprint Curriculum in Computer
Science."
The one problem that we found ourselves with
is
that there was no natural place
to teach Data Structures.
Now, this is a picture of my Ph.D. advisor,
Paul Hilfinger,
who's been teaching Data Structures at Berkley,
for quite a long time,
and I think he would be disappointed looking
at my curriculum
to see we weren't doing justice to Data Structures.
The problem that we ran into, was that
most of the way Data Structures gets taught
is out its context.
Kind of one Data Structure after another.
Lots of pros and cons of this implementation
versus that implementation,
but mostly unmotivated.
So that was stuck in my head,
okay, how are we going to get Data Structures
back
into the curriculum.
At the same time, historically,
we had Complexity Science happening, and it's
a little hard to characterize exactly what
was happening,
and when.
This is a time line from the Wikipedia page
on Complexity Science, that gives some of
the timing
of the major events.
The thing about this that was exciting
to me is that it's all relatively new.
You can study a whole lot of Math and Science
at the undergraduate level before you get
past,
say, the nineteenth century.
There's very little twentieth century math
and science
that you get to, until you get to grad school.
But I thought there was an opportunity there
because Complexity Science, in addition to
being new,
is also very accessible.
I'll talk in a minute
about ways that is accessible.
One of them is, there were lots of
popular nonfiction books written about Complexity.
So I started building a class around that.
Version one of this class was in 2005.
And I started by just grabbing all the books
about this stuff, and trying to figure out
if we could find out what's there.
You know, there's a certain amount of hype,
is there some substance behind it?
And the other thing that I wanted to do was
start with the, start with the popular nonfiction,
which usually doesn't have the technical details
in it.
There's no code.
There's very little mathematics.
But what you can do, in the context of a class,
is start with that, and dive in deeper.
So we found a number of the papers, the original
papers
on these topics.
Student re-implemented
a lot of the models that were described in
those papers.
So that was the first version of the class.
At the end of the class,
I tried to summarize the whole thing
with what I call "the ultra-secret point of
the class."
Because for the whole semester,
we didn't really know yet
what the class was about.
I kind of did the same thing
the second time around.
I felt like I was playing "hide the football"
with the class for the whole semester.
Because I hadn't, in my own head,
got to the point where I could explain
a coherent big picture of it was about.
So I think we were having a good time,
we learned some more Python,
we got some more Data Structures.
We found ourselves talking
about philosophy of science quite a lot,
because the models that were coming up in
Complexity Science
raised a lot of questions about
what exactly are we doing with these models?
What kind of science is this?" [phone rings]
That was the second iteration of the class.
The third iteration was just this past fall,
and I got to do a couple of things.
One of them is, I wrote this book.
I had drafted parts of it,
but I finally sat down and wrote everything
except chapter one.
We used that for the class,
and what the students did over the course
of the semester was, a set of case studies,
where they worked in teams of three or four.
And each of them chose a topic
that could have been a chapter in the book,
but wasn't.
And they wrote the missing chapters of the
book
in the form of these case studies.
And some of them are now included in the book
that you've got.
So this, I thought, was a nice opportunity
to give the students a chance to do some authentic
work
and get published.
In fact, I recruited a program committee to
get
other members of the faculty to do my grading
for me.
So the students turned in their case studies,
I pretended I was the program chair,
and sent out all the papers.
The other faculty wrote reviews,
we decided which ones would be included;
which ones weren't quite ready.
And then I edited in January,
and sent it to the publisher,
and O'Reilly I think does a really good job
of turning books around quickly.
I turned in the manuscript in January,
and I think it was available in March.
Which if you've worked with other publishers,
that's pretty remarkable.
And [claps hands softly]
in January, I finally sat down and wrote
what I think is the "ultra secret point of
the book",
which is the "ultra secret point of the class."
And I will now tell you what it is.
Which is, I think,
the development of Complexity Science
has caused a quiet revolution in science.
What I mean by that is,
what kind of activities do we mean when we
say "science."
What do we think is a good theory?
If you propose an explanation for something,
what's a satisfying explanation?
And maybe hand in hand with that,
what's a good model of a physical system?
I am going to talk about some of the
axes that I think we are moving along.
And I don't mean to say
that this is black and white.
That it used to be a hundred percent this,
and now it's a hundred percent that,
but that I think the center of mass
of scientific activity is gradually shifting
from your point of view, from left to right,
on each of these axes.
From models of physical systems that tend
to be
in the form of equations,
toward things that tend to be
in the form of simulation.
Away from mathematical analysis,
like symbolic computation,
and toward discrete computation.
Continuous mathematics toward discrete mathematics;
linear models, linear systems, toward non-linear
models.
I'll give an example of some of these in a
minute,
I don't want to go too much into details,
but I talk about it more in the book.
Deterministic to stochastic,
I've also mentioned abstract and detailed
in the context of modeling.
What I mean by that is a detailed model
is a realistic description of a physical system.
Where I can look at the physical system,
and the elements of my model,
and there are clear analogs between them.
I can match them up one to one,
and I can say "yep, that's a realistic description
of the system."
And when I say abstract, I mean mostly the
opposite of that.
It’s a more, abstracted; it's a more, less
detailed description,
less realistic.
Some of the other axes,
if you are doing analysis, if you're doing
mathematical computation,
you tend to have to limit yourself to simple
systems
that have a small number of components,
and those components are usually identical.
With computational models,
you can often move
toward large numbers of components,
that can be different, heterogeneous.
Okay, that was pretty abstract.
Let me give a more concrete example.
So, celestial mechanics might be
the canonical example of classical science.
Which I'll just use the term of classical
science,
just to contrast it with, whatever the new
thing is,
maybe complexity science.
So the question is, why are planetary orbits
elliptical?
It's a natural kind of question to ask,
we'd like an explanation of that behavior.
It turns out, if you know the law of Universal
Gravitation,
you can write down a set of differential equations
that describes the motions of planets,
at least for a simplified solar model, solar
system model.
And if you now solve those differential equations,
you get ellipses, and you've explained
why those orbits are ellipses.
And I think there's something very satisfying
about that kind of explanation.
I think at least
most people find it satisfying.
I want to offer, as a point of comparison,
this is Thomas Schelling's model of racial
segregation.
Similarly, it is motivated by a "why" question.
If you look at a lot of cities,
people are segregated by race, so you might
ask "why?"
What he proposed is a model
where the people in your city have two kinds,
in this case, red and green,
and they all live on a two dimensional grid,
so that each of them has eight neighbors,
and the model of their behavior
is that they are happy
if at least a few of their neighbors are like
themselves.
So, if two or three out of the eight are the
same color,
they're happy, and they stay put.
If they have fewer neighbors like themselves,
they start to feel unhappy, and they move,
and moving in this case means just picking
a random, unoccupied cell in the grid,
and moving to it, right?
So, you can characterize the agents,
in this model,
as being mildly xenophobic.
They don't like
to be completely surrounded by people who
are
not like themselves, but you probably wouldn't
describe them as rabid racists.
Nevertheless, the outcome of system tends
to look like what's happening on the right
there,
where things get almost completely segregated
by color, in this case.
And in fact, this is an intermediate step
in the process.
If you keep running that,
it almost just becomes two great big blobs,
with one boundary between them,
depending on the parameters
that you tweak in the system.
The red and green,
anybody colorblind?
Oh alright,
I just, I thought it funny that
the people who made that particular,
graph, made it as inaccessible as possible.
So the question is,
do you find the Newtonian explanation
of elliptical orbits more satisfying
than the Schelling explanation of racial segregation?
I think most people do,
but I want to poke a little bit at why.
There are a few characteristics of classical
science
that make us feel good about it,
but it's not obvious that we are justified
in feeling good.
So one of them is the appeal to a Universal
Law,
in that case we were able to invoke
Universal Gravitation and I think there's
something
about the fact that the same law
applies to things moving on the Earth's surface,
and also to planets moving in solar systems,
that makes us feel like that law has validity,
as opposed to a law that has very narrow scope.
Okay.
There's a certain amount of mathematical virtuosity
that I think impresses us,
and makes the work seem more real.
I have a colleague in Physics that commonly
refers
to the sort of thing I do as
"playing with computers."
So, mathematics is real, playing with computers
is fun and games.
On the other hand I don't want to bias this
too much,
I think that one might have been a little
bit edgy.
But legitimately, predictive power is something
we would like to see in a model or a theory,
and that was, is the great selling point
of Newton's explanation of Celestial Mechanics.
We can predict solar eclipses, we can predict
all sort of things that are going to happen.
That's not as true of Schelling's model.
and "proofiness."
It feels like we've just done
a mathematical proof.
Now, I would say, it's not a proof.
We can't prove
a thing about actual physical systems.
We can proove things about mathematical abstractions,
and we might hope that the proof
about mathematical abstractions is analogous
to something in the real world, but that part's
just a hope.
On the flip side, thinking about Schelling's
model,
the obvious characteristic of Schelling's
model
is that you've just described human beings
by a set of rules,
that says "I'm going to count the number
of my neighbors and be happy
or unhappy depending on that count."
Most sociologists would not be happy
with the reduction that you just made
of human behavior.
The other,
as I mentioned, is that you're just
playing with computers.
And the last is, if models like this
can't make detailed predictions,
that allow us to validate whether
the model is correct or not,
then what kind of work can they do?
So this is the framework that I use
when I teach the class,
and it appears in the book as well,
I think this is a general model
of a lot of what we do when we
model the world, which describes
scientific activity,
but I would also argue
it describes how we think.
Most of our thinking of the world
is in models like this where we have
some physical system that we can observe,
we have either direct or indirect sensory
data.
We then construct a model,
sometimes implicitly, sometimes explicitly,
that is an abstraction of the real thing,
meaning that we've left out details.
The nice thing about the model though,
is that, unlike the real world,
we can write proofs in models,
we can do analysis of models,
we can run simulations of models.
What you get out of that are predictions
and explanations that you can
then compare to whatever it was that you saw
in the physical system, and get some
kind of validation out of that.
This is the framework
at least that I propose to my students.
And then we can ask, what kind of work
does Schelling's model do?
It's not a proof.
It has very little predictive power.
I can't tell you, I can't use Schelling's
model
to tell you how segregated Boston
will be in the future.
But what it does provide is,
kind of a logical argument.
It's an existence proof,
or a kind of counter example
to the assumption
that if you see segregation in a city,
that the people who live there
must be racist.
That the only explanation of segregation
is racist agents.
So the claim, I think,
that Schelling would make is that this
might be sufficient to cause segregation,
but it's not necessary.
You don't have to actually have people behaving
like this in order to see
segregation as the outcome.
And what that means is that
that segregation,
the fact that city seems to be racist,
could be an emergent property.
Meaning that the system as a whole has that
property,
but the components do not.
The individual agents might not be racist.
I want to give one other example
of this kind of model, because I think
a couple of examples will help
us think about it.
I'm going to talk about
the Six Degrees experiment
that Stanley Milgram ran.
How many people are familiar with Stanley
Milgram?
Okay, if you're not,
I highly encourage you to find out more about
him.
I think he's fascinating in part
because he ran two out of the three
most infamous experiments in all of social
science.
One of them, that I just think you have to
read about
if you haven't, is his study
of obedience to authority.
This is the original, one of the original
deceptive, social behavior experiments
where he brought people in,
and told them they were participating
in a teaching and learning experiment,
where they would act as a teacher,
and the "learner" on the other side of the
glass
was actually an actor.
And the subjects were told to administer
electric shocks whenever the "learner"
got the answer wrong.
And they would start out
by giving a fifteen volt shock,
and work their way up a board,
to four hundred fifty volts.
And what would happen,
as you went from fifteen to four hundred fifty;
two things would happen:
one, the warning labels on the board,
would say things like mild shock,
severe shock, hazard, warning, danger,
I don't remember exactly what it was,
but it was increasingly dramatic.
Yellow and black, diamond and stripes,
everything.
Also, the actor on the other side
of the glass, would go from saying things
like "ow",
or "hey stop that" to "I'm having a heart
attack, please stop!"
to silence [hesitant chuckles] at one point.
The nature of the experiment was
to how far up the board people would be willing
to go under different circumstances.
And, some of the circumstances, for example,
would be the "investigator" in a lab coat,
also an actor, standing behind the subject
and saying things like "You must continue,
the experiment requires you to continue."
And you probably see where the punch line
of this is going, which is that many people
will go much farther up the board
than you would like to believe about human
nature.
In fact, something like six--in some conditions,
I forget the exact details, something
like sixty percent of the subjects
went all the way to four hundred and fifty
volts,
and were asking for more.
And--
>> Male speaker 2: I think it was when
the authority assumed, said that they were
assuming all responsibility.
>>Allen: Yeah, you're right.
And there were
different scripts and different layouts
of whether they could see the authority,
or whether they could see the learner, and
so on.
Fascinating stuff, especially because no one
will ever be allowed to run that experiment
again.
[laughter]
>>Allen: Institutional review boards
were pretty much created,
they should be called
the Stanley Milgram Memorial Institutional
Review Boards.
[laughter]
>>Allen: Anyway, fascinating stuff.
Read
more about it if you're not already familiar
with it.
The other experiment that he did, that is
the one that I'm
going to talk a little bit about is
"The Small World" experiment, where he wanted
to investigate the structure of social networks
by seeing whether he could get a package delivered
across the country, following only social
hops.
So, I think he, they started in Wichita, Kansas,
and they had a couple of different targets,
one of them was a stockbroker in Sharon, Massachusetts.
My father was a stockbroker in Sharon, Massachusetts,
but not the target of the Milgram experiment.
[laughter]
>> Allen: The idea was that
Milgram, or one of his associates
would give a package to someone and say, "I
want you to deliver this to
this person" and they would be given
the name, occupation, and where they lived,
but the rules are you can only give this
to someone that you know personally.
So, if you know the target personally,
you can just go give it to them, and you're
done,
and otherwise you have to give it to someone
that you know personally.
What he wanted to know was,
how many hops it would take to get from Wichita
to Sharon, Massachusetts.
And this graph shows the distribution
of hops for the packages that were delivered.
Now, not all of the packages were delivered,
so there's a bias behind this, and that's
been the subject of a lot of discussion
but the interesting thing about this is
that the mode is at six.
It took six hops
most often to get from source to destination,
and that's where the six degrees of separation
term
comes from, alright?
So at the time, very little was known
about the structure of social networks,
since then, it's been the subject of a lot
of study,
and we have several good explanations
of why the diameter of these social graphs
seems to be so much shorter than you would
expect.
So that's the good thing that we have lots
of explanations.
The bad thing is
we have too many explanations,
and they're incompatible.
So, there are two models
that people have proposed
simplified topologies that capture
important elements of social networks.
Watts and Strogatz had what they
call a Small World Graph, which is a parameterized
graph
between a completely regular graph on one
end,
and a completely random graph on the other,
and what they find is a sweet spot in the
middle
that behaves like social networks,
in the sense that it is highly clustered,
meaning that your friends tend to know each
other,
but also has a small diameter,
meaning that it has this small world behavior.
So that's one possible explanation.
The other is Barabasi and Albert's model,
which is a scale free network.
The way you build one of these is
by growing it.
So if you start out with one,
or a small number of nodes,
and gradually add nodes,
with the property of preferential attachment,
meaning the rich get richer,
and/or don't go as fast,
what you get is a high,
a long tailed distribution of degree
in the network.
Most people have
a small number of friends,
but there are a few people
who have a very large number of friends.
That graph also has the Small World Property,
and so now, if you're trying to explain
the Small World Property,
you don't know which explanation is right.
This is part of the reason
in my class that I found myself inevitably
talking
about philosophy of science,
because we just left the world of doing science,
building models,
and using them to predict, explain and design.
What we're now talking about is
theory choice.
Why should I
prefer one model, or theory,
over another?
And so that led us to Thomas Kuhn,
who wrote The Structure of Scientific Revolutions,
which is probably his most famous book.
If you're not familiar with that book in particular,
you're almost certainly familiar with
Paradigm Shifts.
That book introduced
that term.
So all the bad jokes
about paradigm shifts that we've had
for the last, let's see,
since 1963 or 4.
You can
blame Thomas Kuhn for that
particular piece of vocabulary.
He also wrote an essay called
"Objectivity, Value Judgment, and Theory Choice"
which is explicitly about the situation
we were just talking about.
Two competing models,
in some sense they both explain the data,
so you can't choose one over the other
purely in terms of how well it fits data.
There have to be other criteria,
and that's exactly what he explains.
Well, what are those other criteria?
Both descriptively,
like if we watch scientists
and listen to what they say,
what are the criteria that they seem
to be applying?
And also normatively, which is,
which of those criteria do we think
are justified?
And which might be biased?
One of the reasons that the class
inevitably ends up in philosophy was...
explained nicely by xkcd, which found
that the structure of information,
at least as represented by Wikipedia,
has a tendency to lead inevitably to philosophy.
And this came out by the experiment
that if you take any article,
and click on the first link,
and repeat that process,
you will eventually end up at "Philosophy."
if you haven't read that cartoon,
I recommend it to you.
so I took some of the things
that we were talking about in the class,
and made them into a running theme throughout
the book.
So each chapter tends to raise a different
issue
in philosophy of science, and then I tried
to
write a little bit about it, just enough
to introduce what I thought were interesting
questions
and hopefully point you to toward more reading.
I mentioned Theory Choice as one of the first
topics
that comes up.
The Demarcation problem is one of the others.
The Demarcation problem is, is there a justified
definition
of science that lets us distinguish between
things
that are real science, good science,
and other things like pseudo-science, or,
that
seem that like they might be sciencey, but
they're not?
Or say, religion, things that are not science
at all,
but how do we clearly, justify that definition?
Realism and instrumentalism comes up quite
a lot.
This is, this pertains to how we interpret
the theories and models that we're using
to describe physical systems.
I won't say too much
about that now, I'm going to come back to
it
just a little bit later.
Holism and reductionism was one of the other
topics
that comes up.
Again I won't say too much about that
right now.
But I will come back to as I said,
the ultra secret point of this book.
I started with this set of axes,
at the beginning,
and I speculate, or at least my thesis
that we are living through a transition
toward a new kind of science.
I'm kind of borrowing that phrase
from Steven Wolfram,
but I mean it in a different sense then he
does.
So, I'm going to have to violate
his trademark on that phrase.
He is primarily talking about, well,
actually tell you what, if you want
to know what Wolfram is saying
when he says new kind of science,
ask me after, let's not go down that.
What I mean by it is just
what I was saying before,
the shift along these axes
in what we think is science; what we think
is a good model; what we think
is a satisfying kind of explanation; what
we think is good work for a scientist to do.
I think there are some other shifts going
on at the same time
that are related.
One of them is what kind of work
do we want models to do?
With the Newton example,
and the Schelling example, I wanted to show
what I think is a shift for models that are
primarily meant to be predictive.
They were often
tools that we would use as computational devices,
for making predictions that had practical
consequences.
I think there's a shift toward models
that may be explanatory without necessarily
having predictive property.
I mentioned realism and instrumentalism,
alright, let me finally say what I mean by
that.
Let me throw out an idea.
Are electrons real?
By a common language use of the word real?
Alright, so I think we would all buy, or at
least
I'll ask you to accept, that chair is real.
Okay?
Unicorns are not real.
So on that axis of real/not real,
[laughter] what's your feeling about electrons?
>>male speaker 2: Not real.
[muffled laughter]
>>Allen: Not real?
>>male speaker 2: They are merely an abstraction.
>>Allen: They might be a useful abstraction,
and you can
certainly take that view.
That would be an instrumentalist
interpretation of a theory involving electrons.
Now, here's a trivial thing that you can do
with that theory,
electrons, for historical reasons,
have negative charge.
You could imagine a whole new
physics of the world where you just flip the
science
of everything.
Okay?
That new physics would be just
as good as the old physics, except that electrons,
in some sense would be different.
They would have positive charge.
And it's clear that you haven't done any work
by doing that transition,
but it does suggest that the entities that
make up your model
are in, some sense, arbitrary.
I could have...
>>male speaker 2: The charge is arbitrary,
the numbers arbitrary [unintelligible]
>>Allen: Yeah.
Right, so in that case,
I haven't really done much,
but I could imagine another physics
that postulated a different
set of entities.
More different
than just positive and negative charge.
And that other physics might be
just as good as what we currently call physics.
It's not easy to make one up as a good example
but it's at least imaginable.
Anyway, that discussion would take
you down the road toward talking about
realism and instrumentalism.
the other one is reductionism and holism.
I'm torn about how far to get into that one.
Hofstadter talks about this in Gödel, Escher
and Bach.
This is one of his figures
that I kind of like because it's a nice
way to think of things that you would interpret
differently at different scales.
And that's
related to reductionism and holism.
I think
I'm going to punt on that for now, but we'll
give you chance to talk about it later if
you want to.
If there's a new kind of science going on
here,
one could imagine there'd be a new kind of
engineering
that goes with it.
And I think there is.
These, again, are some of the axes where I
think
we're shifting over time.
Away from engineered systems
that tended to be centralized toward decentralized
systems.
Isolation, interaction what I mean by that
is, that in a lot
of engineering design, if you want to build
something complex,
that involves many subsystems, you want to
be able
to design each subsystem in isolation
without having to worry about all the others
at the same time.
In the context of, software, this is often
described in terms
of abstraction and encapsulation, but it's
a fundamental idea through all of engineering,
that if every component of your system depends
on every other component, you very quickly
won't
be able to design anything.
It will collapse
under the weight of its own complexity.
But that's increasingly, I won't say not true,
I'll say less true that we now have more
tools for dealing with complexity, and that
allows us to relax a little bit the requirement
that everything be very carefully isolated.
We can design things that have more interacting
components now, and still be able to manage
that.
One of the ways of managing that is to replace
classical analysis with computation.
You can design
more complicated things if you throw
more computational power at it.
One example of that,
does anybody know what that building is?
>>male speaker 2: The Guggenheim Museum...
>>Allen: The Guggenheim Museum in Bilbao,
Spain.
Who designed it?
>> male speaker 2: Frank Gehry
>>Allen: Anything else around here also designed
by Frank Gehry?
[laughter]
>>Allen: Stata center.
Is it Stah-ta or state-a?
>>Male speaker 3: Stahta
>>Male speaker 4: State-a, I think.
>>Allen: Okay.
>>Male speaker 4: The guy's name is State-a,
but the people who work there call it
Stah-ta Center.
>>Allen: Interesting.
Okay.
[Laughter]
>>Allen: So, one of the reasons they were
able to build
that thing is that they used CAD software
that had been
developed for designing boats, and Gehry's
innovation
was to apply it to buildings.
It would not have been
possible or feasible to design or build that
prior to the
availability of that software, in the same
way it wasn't
feasible to design or build the Eiffel Tower
prior to
Eiffel's development of analytic techniques
for designing and analyzing those types of
structures.
The other piece of this that I think
is interesting is that, I think, increasingly
we will search for engineering solutions,
rather than design them.
And maybe
I'll just leave it at that.
One more piece of this, so I'm speculating
on a new kind of science, a new kind of modeling,
a new kind of engineering, and here's a new
kind
of thinking.
Which is, I think, our fascination with
Aristotelian logic will gradually fade, and
be
replaced by some kind of multi-valued logic.
Being kind of a Bayesian myself, I'm
biased toward Bayesianism as my favorite
multi-valued logic.
But that inevitably
takes you on the road from imagining that
your scientific theories are objective,
or that your beliefs about the world are objective,
toward acknowledging that they're subjective,
and if they are, then what?
Subjectivity seems like a dangerous slope
toward pure relativism, you know,
what's true is true for me, what's true for
you
is true for you, and we can't talk to each
other.
That, doesn't seem to be the case, so it raises
the question can we have subjectivity without
complete collapse?
A couple of other shifts that I think are
going on,
away from thinking of scientific theories
in terms
of Universal Physical Laws, more toward theories
and models.
I would argue that there's no meaningful difference
between a theory and a model, that when you
tell me that you're,
that you have a theory, what you're really
doing
is recommending a model to me.
And the language that
we would use for choosing one of those models
again goes back to subjectivity and theory
choice.
The discussion that Kuhn brings up.
And the last is away from determinism and
into indeterminism.
So, I kinda blew through
a lot of this, in part, because, me standing
up here,
and talking about it, is not the most effective
thing.
I, part of the reason that I wrote this down,
is that I think it's better to read a careful
exposition
of it, than to get the thoughts off the top
of my head.
But more importantly, what you really need
to do
is wrestle with the stuff.
So just reading what I think
isn't going to get you very far,
what I really want you to do is is pick up
the book,
and do some of the exercises, and, as I'll
talk about in a minute,
I wanna get you to write a, a case study.
but just to finish off a couple of thoughts
here,
I hope you'll read the book.
I think the Complexity
Science stuff might be fun for you, and I
think
parts of it are probably familiar to each
i, each of you,
but it's unlikely that all of you are familiar
with all of it.
So there might be some good stuff there.
The philosophy of science might be new to
you,
unless that's a hobby of yours.
The analysis
of algorithm stuff is probably not that new
to many of you, at least the software engineers.
And similarly, intermediate Python; those
are two topics that suited my class that may,
or may not
be the most important to you.
Alright, the case studies!
So I mentioned that the students worked on
case studies,
and we picked the best ones, and then we published
them.
We're planning to do the same thing with the
next edition
of the book.
So if you're familiar with the cookbook,
books, that O'Reilly does.
So the Python cookbook, for example,
they collected a bunch of short articles,
where someone would explain a recurring problem,
and give a solution to it, and explain the
alternatives.
They published a bunch of them and then there's
a webpage
that collects submissions, and then every
once in a while,
they seem to collect all the good ones off
the webpage,
and that becomes the next edition of the book.
[coughing]
So, we're thinking of something similar,
just because there's so much good stuff here,
and I didn't want to, and couldn't, cram it
all into the book,
so I've left some for my students,
and they've left some for you.
Some of the ones they've done so far,
this is an ant trail model, which is another
agent based model.
We have a very simple model of ant behavior
here, their decisions
whether they will turn left or right, and
how they propagate out
from the nest.
The interesting thing about that model is
that a very simple system reproduces trails
that are
at least qualitatively similar actual ant
trails,
but maybe more interestingly, different species
of ants,
have different foraging patterns, and if you
track them,
and look at the shape of those trails, they
have distinctive texture,
to them.
You could look at them and visually identify
which species it was, by the structure of
those trails.
This model has a few perimeters that you can
turn
that will make the trails look like species
one, or species two,
or species three, depending on how you tweak
it.
So, it's a nice model.
Slime molds are another classic,
agent based model where the emergent behavior
of the system,
is different in character from the behavior
of the individual agents,
and surprising.
And the surprising-ness might be
an important characteristic of emergent properties.
Another student project looked at the distribution
of wealth.
It's common observation that in a lot
of economic systems, the distribution of wealth
quickly becomes long tailed.
That seems to be hard
to avoid, and hard to fix.
The system tends
to gravitate to those long tailed distributions,
and you might wonder why.
Sugarscape is, again,
a very abstract, very not realistic model
of an "economy" of a kind.
A sugar economy.
but it develops long tailed distributions
in ways, that I think, can be explanatory.
A knot in Wikipedia, if you have a directed
graph,
and you follow links through the graph, you
might
find that you've arrived in a neighborhood
that you can no longer get out of.
[laughter]
And so the students were searching to see
whether
a directed graph created by Wikipedia
has knots in it.
Norms game, is related to iterated prisoner's
dilemma.
And then I had one student that took on a
very
ambitious project that didn't quite get to
the finish line,
that's not in the book, but they did a lot
of very cool stuff,
with the evolution of virtual creatures.
So the creatures
would have a genotype, that would describe
their phenotype
in a simulated three-dimensional environment.
And so, you would
evolve them over time, by having them interact
in this simulated 3D world.
Have some kind of fitness contest
to see who gets to be represented in the next
generation,
and then follow the gene pool over time.
What they discovered,
and lots of people have built versions of
this, is that the animals
discover lots of innovative solutions to problems
like,
gathering food, and hitting each other,
and locomotion and things like that.
Including the ability
to exploit bugs in your simulation of the
3D world.
[laughter]
>>male speaker 4: They discover magic.
>>Allen: That's right, they discover magic.
[laughter]
One of the things that they discovered was
that there was an error in the boundary condition
so that
if you were, if your critter was very close
to the boundary,
and kind of moving back and forth across the
boundary of the world,
it would start translating along one of the
axes much faster than
anything else in the world could move, and
they kind of discovered
the transporter, and animals were exploiting
it.
And when they were running away from something,
they would head
for the boundary, and then zip along.
[laughter]
Okay, just a couple of thoughts about things
I'm currently working on.
In seven days, I need to turn in the manuscript
of Think Python,
and they're going to try and turn it around
and make it available by July, so we'll see
how all that goes.
This is the second draft of the cover.
I have to tell you a little bit of the story
of the cover.
You might know that O'Reilly puts animals
on all the covers
and a lot of people have wondered, who gets
to choose
the animals.
They actually have a person
who works full time; that’s her job; she
picks the animals.
[laughter]
And they tell you, if you're an author,
they tell you very explicitly don't try to
pick your animal.
We don't want to hear it.
The most input that you get is that if you
can give a few words
that describe the character of your book,
that will help
the animal chooser choose your animal.
Although for my books, so far,
they haven't even asked me for adjectives,
they've just
given me an animal.
Now, I've been happy so far.
I've got
an Archerfish on the statistics book, which
is a really cool,
I don't know if you know about the Archerfish,
but it has
a little groove in its throat and it shoots
a jet of water,
out of the water, and it hits insects.
So if an insect
is out on a branch, it will shoot this jet
of water, knock it
off the branch into the water,
and then the Archerfish swims over and eats
it.
And it turns out that it can shoot out of
the water hit things
about two meters away with high accuracy,
sorta, you know, insect size
precision, despite the fact that its eyes
are underwater
and it’s going out into air, so it’s got
the refraction at the surface of the water,
that throws off,
so it compensates for refraction and hits
things.
So cool animal,
really happy with that.
This is, I believe, a Black Eagle,
now I forget, it's on the last page
of the book so if you want to look it up.
So, okay, it doesn't shoot water or anything,
but [laughter] it's, it's cool enough.
The Python book, the first draft of the cover
came back
with, all together now.
>>[all together] A python!
>>Allen: A python.
Just like almost every other Python book,
with a couple of exceptions, so I wrote back
and said,
"The Python's fine, and if you want to go
with that,
no problem, but Python, the programming language,
is named
after Monty Python.
It's not named after the snake, so
every time someone puts a python on the cover
of a Python book,
you're basically saying, “we didn't get
the joke."[laughter]
So, so here's a suggestion, can we put a dead
parrot on the cover?"
[loud laughter]
>>male speaker 5: A Norwegian blue.
>>Allen: A Norwegian blue, exactly right.
So, and the only thing
I had to say was, the text at the end of the
book
that describes the animal that's on the cover,
I said, "Look, if you'll please put a parrot
on the cover,
you could have a lot of fun with the text
at the end because
you could basically lift lines out of the
sketch, 'A Norwegian blue,
beautiful plumage isn't it?'
That kind of thing."
So they went along with it, I believe this
is not actually
a Norwegian Blue Parrot, because there's no
such thing.
[laughter]
But as far as I'm concerned, that's a Norwegian
Blue Parrot.
[laughter] I haven't yet, I haven't seen the
text that they've
written yet, but I'm going to try to convince
them
to actually say it's a Norwegian Blue Parrot
and see if people get it.
Projects that are up next, is anybody familiar
with The Little Book of Semaphores?
I don't know if that's crossed
anybody's path.
I wrote a book a number of years ago
where I took all the fun, synchronization
puzzles, like
readers/writers, but also the Santa Claus
problem, Dining Philosophers,
what are the other fun ones?
There's Dining Savages.
If you took an operating systems class, you
might have done one of these.
>>male speaker 6: The Banker?
>>Allen: Which one?
>>Allen: Oh yeah, now that's the deadlock
one, right?
>>male speaker 6: Yeah.
>>Allen: Yeah, no, I didn't do a lot with
deadlock,
but anyway, collected a bunch of synchronization
puzzles,
and I'm thinking of turning that into a book
called
Think Synch, and I'm also thinking about linear
Algebra.
So there might be a Think Linear, at some
point.
If you want to follow the progress, [clears
throat]
Green Tea Press, is me.
Green Tea Press is where
I publish the first drafts of all my books.
And then see if I can find a publisher that
that wants to work with them.
But while I am
developing them, they're all available under
free
licenses.
For a while I was using Gnu Free Documentation
License, lately I've been using a lot of the
Creative
Commons licenses, but the nice thing is that
you can
modify these books; you can translate them
into other languages;
you can pull chapters out of several different
books and
and recombine them.
So there a lot of cool projects
that I think come from making material available
like that.
The Python book, that is the origin of the
Statistics book,
and the Complexity book was originally a Java
book,
that somebody else translated from Java into
Python, and sent
it back to me, and I actually learned Python
by reading my own book.
[laughter] Which was very strange.
[laughter] Because I recognized
my writing [laughter] but it was telling me
things I didn't know.
[laughter] And it's kind of like those time
travel plots [xylophone sounds]
where you from the future comes and tells
you things.
That's exactly [laughter]
So I've had that experience.
So, yes, check out the free books,
read Think Complexity, write a case study.
I think that's all I wanted to talk about
for now,
but I'm happy to take questions, or hear comments,
or.
>>male speaker 7: My question is, that I have
to interview new candidates
at Google, often around, you know, algorithms
and complexity.
Do you have good questions, because you know,
most of them are banned now.
>>Allen: Right.
[laughter] I'll have to think about that,
because this, we're taking a kind of different
approach
to it, and that might actually lend itself
to the next generation of algorithm design
questions.
Cause, it used to be kind of a test of the
canon,
there, how much of Corn, Mueller, Silver and
Ruest have you absorbed
and can deliver on request?
Usually applied in non-trivial
ways, so I mean, the thing I like about the
questions is
a lot of what you learn by memorizing the
data structures book,
you might not be able to apply in flexible
ways to a new problem.
I think that is what interview questions are
really testing so
I think that's the good part.
But, I'm kinda, I'm getting away from this
canonical idea that you have to know three
kinds leveling,
balancing, self-balancing treatise, or that
you have to know
five implementations of a queue and all the
pros and cons
of them.
>>male speaker 8: That's because we design
by search now.
>>Allen: Because we design by search, yeah.
So, I mean,
I think there is a different tool kit now,
and a different
set of knowledge.
I think there are a number of sufficiently
solved problems that we kinda don't really
need to think much
about their implementations, at least a very
small number
of people will, the vast majority of us will
now work above
that level of abstraction, so let's put some
of that stuff aside
and thing about what are the interesting and
hard questions
now at that level.
But I don't have any great ones
off the top of my head, but I love the question.
>> David: You talked about moving from,
the predictive to the explanatory,
>>Allen: Um hmm.
>>David: But we still need predictions.
>>Allen: Sure
>>David: Even in the complex worlds, in true
learning
new things.
>>Allen: Sure.
>>David: If it's true science is moving from
here to there,
but I take it you're saying, we're evil if
we move over here
to discover more new things per decade, than
if we just stayed where
we were, where we kind of mind, the kind of
things that gave us [unintelligible] mechanics,
>>Allen: Yes.
>>David: But in truth, you're giving us a
model of science,
you're saying we're likely to get more discoveries
per decade
if we move over here, but we need a prediction
about how many more?
For example, if I had one of these scale free
networks graphs,
and I build the largest social networks in
the world,
is that worth one hundred billion dollars?
[laughter]
>>Allen: So yes, we still need models that
are capable of prediction,
I think, when I'm describing that shift, I
think two things are going on.
One of them is we are relaxing the requirement
that every model be predictive, and admitting
that there can be good science
at the other end of the spectrum.
That, if, there's lots of good work
to be done there, even if we relax the requirement
to be predictive.
and the other is that we can be a little more
fearless
about attacking large, complex, heterogeneous
systems that,
I think for a long time we would have avoided
because we knew we wouldn't be
able to make any progress on them, with the
tools that we had.
Now, with a different set of tools, we can
start to attack
a bigger set of problems.
Yeah?
>>male speaker 10: I had a question about
the trend towards instrumentalism.
>>Allen: Mm hmm.
>>male speaker 10: When we talked about does
as electrons exist,
I was kind of reminded of this Xeno School
of Paradoxes.
One of the paradoxes was the millet paradox,
right?
>>Allen: I don't think I know that.
>>male speaker 10: Why does a bag of millet
when dropped make a sound, when a single pellet
of millet when dropped, does not make a sound.
You know, I think this talk both to their
summation
and their use of perception as a means of
determining
reality.
All right, so the Greeks said "well, sound
doesn't exist
unless my ear can actually hear it."
Right, an electron,
in my understanding is, it's real in the sense
of you you can prove
what is it, the Thompson's experiment, the
thing about the droplets moving
at these discrete velocities, and that there's
a quantized charge.
And so, one can assign quantification of that,
like are we moving
towards a trend of other things being considered
like, rayified,
like traffic jam or some type of common phenomenon
as some sort of real, ya know,
as part of your paradigm shift?
>>Allen: Right, Okay.
So I think, so the Xeno example
is one of those cases where
the two endpoints are clear, and, but something
must change in the middle, but we have a really
hard time saying where it changed in the middle,
and I think
realism and instrumentalism has that character
as well.
There are some examples where the vast majority
of us feel entirely comfortable saying,
"Yup, that's real."
At the other end
of the spectrum, things that we all, at least
have a consensus,
that they're not, something in the middle,
there has
to be a transition somewhere in the middle.
Where do we put it?
One way to resolve that is to say,
is to accept as real, any entity postulated
by a theory that we use.
So if it's a good theory,
then the entities that it postulates are real.
In other words, you just expand the space
of what you're willing to call real,
to make the conflict go away.
The other is
to go all the way to instrumentalism,
and say that all of our theories are tools
that we use to explain stuff, and we're not
obligated
to consider any of our hypostulated entities
as real.
Even things that seem even obviously real,
like nice firm objects,
which at the Mezzo scale of physics, have
nice reality to them,
but if you go to very small scales, that starts
to get fuzzy.
Now with nice solid objects, I think we have
a hard time with it.
One of the examples I like to use is mushrooms.
When when you look at a mushroom, what you're
actually
looking at is this fruiting body of a fungus.
And that thing
that's discrete and we pick up and eat, seems
to have nice
realness to it.
But that organism, that you just harvested,
is actually a very fine network of cells that
is mostly underground.
The underground part might be hundreds or
thousands, or millions of times
more massive than the thing you just picked
up.
So in the sense of being big,
and concrete, it's real, but it's also
really diffuse.
It doesn't have borders that can track.
You couldn't dig it up,
you would end up digging up an acre of land.
And you couldn't separate it from the soil
that it's part of, so it has some of the characteristics
that we associate with nice, concrete, well
delineated objects,
but not all of them.
That's one of those
weird middle test cases, that I like to think
about.
One of the other ones that's a little bit
fun is
trying to figure out which atoms
do you consider to be you.
[laughter]
Okay, one of them is, if you weigh
yourself, you get the total
mass of the stuff that you consider to be
you,
but that includes cells that have your DNA,
those seem like they're probably you.
But it also includes a lot of dead stuff,
that may or may not be you,
it includes a lot of other organisms,
like the bacteria that live in your gut,
and the mites that live in your eyebrows,
and all kinds of other things, that again,
you know, so are you a symbiotic colony of
all those things?
You could have a lot of fun with this.
Sorry if I'm wondering around a little bit.
Yes?
>>David: We have time for one more question
if anyone has one.
>>Allen: Great, yes?
>>male speaker 11: One thing, this is going
to be a vague wandering question.
>>Allen: I will give you a vague wandering
answer.
>>Male speaker 11: The problems that human
brains seem to have
dealing with complexity, one of the main manifestations
of that
is very smart people make very stupid mistakes.
NASA's been pretty good at that with centimeters
versus
inches, things crashing and
and then the sort of recurrence of the number
a hundred and fifty, which is shortly the
size of a village,
and the number of social connections, are
there
do you think there are limitations to our
physical limitations even,
to our brain in dealing with increasing complexity?
Are there ways out of that?
>>Allen: Right.
Umm, it does seem clear
that there are aspects
of human psychology that influence what we
consider
to be good theories and bad theories, and
also
our decisions about real and not real, and
all that.
And that does seem to to be a consequence
of the environment that our brains evolved
in.
And it comes with a certain set of capabilities,
things that we're really good at,
and also as you said, certain types of lapses,
where things like engineering systems
tend to poke at the exactly spots in our brains
that are kind of soft.
So I promised a vague and sort of wandering
answer,
and I think that might have been it.
[quiet laughter]
So I think the challenge then for theory choice
is to distinguish between what are the preferences
we have,
just because that's how we are, versus preferences
that we can justify in terms of properties
such as being truth tropic.
You know, I think this is more likely to lead
toward more truth,
you know, I think this theory is better than
that one,
not just because my monkey brain tells me
that it's better,
but because I've got a justified reason to
believe that it's
more likely to lead to, lead toward a truth,
be good for prediction,
whatever the other characteristics are that
we have for a model.
>>David: Alright.
>>Allen: Thank you very much.
[Loud applause]